with rebel heart film and the artists
that you plan to
speak to across the country what tips
would you share with them
on keeping their budget down
wow there's so many
there are so many in the script i mean
just look at your script
realistically and everything that's not
necessary get rid of it i mean if it
doesn't serve the story
it doesn't need to be there i mean
that's that's like first and foremost
because you know that in post-production
in editing you're probably going to lose
a lot of stuff that you didn't need
so this should not be more than 100
pages yeah if it doesn't serve the story
lose it because don't shoot stuff you're
not going to use you're not going to use
more than 100 pages worth of
footage it's just not going to happen
you're not me unless you're making one
piece
you're not making more of these um is
that's definitely
that's definitely like i would go that
would be the number one thing
make sure if if it's like you know
between
95 to 100 pages you're in the right
ballpark once you start getting into 120
pages
you're just stroking your own ego and
you're just shooting stuff that's going
to end up on the floor you know so why
waste days that are
you know that you know that costs money
for stuff that you're not going to use
another thing i would say is just from
like day one
is you know use and it's that thing like
conceive your script around what you
have and use what you have so
as i said about lydia something that we
were you know a way that we really kept
our costs down was we use locations that
we didn't have to pay for
you know so i i mean it's an old thing
saying oh
you know think of a movie that can be
shot in your house or you know just use
the things like
at the car in the film with our car
everything it's it's finding these
it's being sort of ingenious about
making use of what you can get for free
that is going to keep your budget way
down it's when you have to start paying
thing for you know each of those things
that uh costs can mount
when you ask people for locations that
you want to shoot at don't tell them
you're shooting a film
tell them you're shooting a video always
play it down
never play it up always say like it's
just a little student video
we're just doing this later make sure
you have at least one producer with a
student id
yeah we're doing a psa we're doing a
public service announcement
and that's all we're doing it's nothing
big it's nothing fancy
and always play it down and the more you
play it down the more likely
two things more likely you are to get
the location
and um the other thing is is that
they all feel sorry for you and give it
to you cheaper than
what they would normally give it to a
film for you know i think also though
it's a kind of like i mean it's really
being strategic when we've obviously
gone to a conversation about locations
but locations can be such a huge cost in
your film
um one of the locations obsalidia that
was really a star for us was the
museum of jurassic technology which is a
museum here in los angeles that
a lot of people have tried to film in
before and they never allowed a camera
crew in before
and you know the reason that we managed
to get permission and we didn't have to
pay for it
we didn't pay a dime we were prepared to
pay for it but he gave it to us he gave
it to us was
you know it was just that thing about we
created a relationship with uh
david wilson who owns and created the
museum i
you know i gave him the script i talked
to him about why it was so important to
have the museum in
the film what it represented why it was
like an integral part of the story and
it wasn't just something
you know like oh wouldn't this be cool
you know it was like everything had a
reason and
you know and he ended up you know really
being a huge fan of the
the script and then the project and so
he wanted to support it
and i think like you know overall like
that sort of tactic as a way
you know if we're talking about how to
save money and your budget overall
is to take that sort of grassroots
community approach to get people
involved and it's not about getting
people to do stuff for free and
you know like you know it but it is like
creating a community who are
investing in the film in different ways
you know so that you know it's not about
the money and
one of the things i wrote actually in
that craigslist ad right in the
beginning when i was looking for a line
producer
was you know if you're looking for a
money gig this is not that film
you know this is a film to do because
you absolutely love
the idea of this film and you want to be
involved in helping make it
get made you know and if you feel that
and you enjoy
you like the people that you meet who
are already working on it then this is
you know then it's a film for you but
it's not about the money and i think the
more that you can attract people and
again
it's not about like not paying people
because i like everybody did get paid on
obviously
except for us we had deferred payments
but everybody else did get paid you know
and i think that's important
and because they they deserve to be
they're doing work you know
um but a way to keep the cost down is to
really get everyone inspired so there is
like this feeling of
you know we're trying to do something
together as a community and we're all
investing in it
and that that will help keep your budget
down because you will find
numerous ways to cut costs and an
example another example of that in a
certain way is
that chris would make breakfast for
everybody but fantastic breakfast so you
know like our catering budget was
slashed because we're making the food
but again that's something that's like
it seems like oh it's just about cutting
the cost but it's actually about
creating
a community thing again you know because
they feel cared for
when the crew come up and it's like use
you know like making the food and you
like you've put some love and heart into
that food for them
you've been doing it since two o'clock
in the morning yeah yeah but i slept in
a tent
yeah so i feel like there is a you know
it's just you know that question about
how to cut cross you know also to me
feeds in it's like
how to make a movie in a way that's like
you know that's more
fulfilling for everybody and it's not
about the money you know and engaging
everybody who works on the film
and everybody who's partaking it as much
as possible into that
philosophy the painful decision
to cut certain scenes that you really
wanted
but the cost was just too much whether
it was the scene with the cat or the kid
that you'd plan to put in the film what
was there any moment where you really
had to
hunker down and say how can we not use
this scene but
still have it relevant something no
absolutely absolutely i think that
happens all the time like i think for me
and also in my second film
i think that came up a lot as well um
where you're going
okay we can't afford to do this but you
know for me as a writer and it's
fortunate if you're the you know if
you're the director and you're also the
writer you can
if you figure these things out you think
okay we can't afford to do that
what is the essence of this scene though
why is it there what is the you know
what's the story beat what is what we
learn about the camera you know and how
can we
maintain that and retain the heart of
what's going on
but do it in a way that won't cost as
much and i think there's
always a creative answer to that and
there's always a way to do it and it's
it's not painful
um there is definitely there's a phrase
that people say about filmmaking
uh you have to be willing to kill your
babies i'm sure you've heard that many
times
and you know it's absolutely true and
that that's part of it though too you
know sometimes you think
that is one of the best pieces of
dialogue i've written in my life and now
i have to cut it you know
um but i think if it's really that great
it will find a way at some other time
like if you've come up with a line
that's like amazing it will find another
place you know
if you've come up with an idea for a
scene i think like you know it will
happen some other way like i
feel like again it's practicing
non-attachment but uh
you know you let it go you just you
focus constantly what's the heart what's
what is essential i've heard also about
screenwriting and i think it's true of
filmmaking too which is like
it's like a line drawing and you just
want to like narrow it down to that line
you know
um don't you don't convolute it at all
it's like try to draw that person in one
single line
and i think a film is like really get
rid of everything that's not necessary
that goes into
like the budget thing that you said
before you know to
help keep the budget low get rid of
everything that's not necessary and
actually you'll probably find that you
make a better film because of that
you